thanks Sarah now I want to merge the
coin branch and the master branch
together after the merge I'll want the
master branch to update and point to the
merged version so if I didn't already
have the master branch checked out I
would check it out now I'll just verify
and yes I am on the master branch
already I'll run git merge master coins
to create a merged version of the two
branches when I hit enter my editor pops
up so that I can type a commit message
for the merge commit unlike the other
commits this one comes with a default
commit message merge branch coins I
could change it if I want to but leaving
it like this makes it clear when I've
merged two branches so I'll just leave
it as is so git lets me know that it
made the merge and the file game is has
changed if I run git log I can see the
merge commit now I'll go ahead and test
whether this worked if it did I should
see both color and coins when I run the
code well I can see that there's color
and there's a coin it looks like the
merge worked correctly one thing you
might notice though is that the coin is
not colorful like the rest of the game
that makes sense
git only merges the literal changes that
you make and the code to add this coin
added a non colorful version now if I
run git log again I can still see the
merge commit and I can see these commits
added by me and Doug and there's also
some commits by Sarah interleaved with
the commits by me and Doug since the
commits are sorted by the time they were
created now this causes an interesting
side effect on git diff let's say I
wanted to view the difference between
these two commits I could do it and I
would see the difference between them
but this commit is not the parent of
this one so I wouldn't just see the
changes introduced by this commit let's
try it out now as you can see there are
quite a few changes in this diff but
actually this commit was pretty small to
see just the changes introduced by this
commit I'd have to dip it against its
parent but how do I know what the parent
was well get includes a command called
git show which will show you what
changes were introduced by a commit
compared to its parent so that way I can
see the disk omit and its parent without
actually knowing what the parent was and
now there's a much smaller diff since I
don't need the coins branch anymore I'll
delete it using the command git branch -
D coins where D stands for delete this
won't delete the commits in the branch
it will only delete the label that could
have made the commits hard to find but
those commits are now reachable from the
master branch so it's not a problem here
you can see it lets me know that I've
deleted to the branch to get some
practice creating a merge commit go
ahead and repeat my steps on your own
computer if you haven't been following
along if you're interested you can also
introduce a new commit making the coin
solid and yellow but this is optional
since you weren't required to have
experience with JavaScript if you do
want to make the coin solid and yellow I
recommend using git diff and get show to
see what code was introduced in both
branches otherwise the solution video
will contain instructions for how to
make this commit if you're curious did
you merge the branches on your own
computer select the most accurate option